good afternoon so today as the
penultimate session here I'm going to
talk about the topic that's going to
utilize everything you have learned so
far your little replication little
pathogenesis some retrovirology little
epidemiology and we're going to use all
of that to talk about a story involving
what maybe a new human retrovirus called
XMRV so this starts this whole story
starts with prostate cancer prostate
cancer is a disease that in that occurs
in two forms there is a sporadic form of
the disease where the prevalence
increases with age so a risk factor is
age and then there is a familial form
where genetics is involved and you're
predisposed to developing the cancer
depending on what's been present in your
family and this is typically early onset
less than 55 years old a number of
studies have shown that perhaps another
risk factor for prostate cancer is a
mutation in RNA cell so RNA Sal remember
it's a interferon stimulated gene
product that's involved in cutting up
the genomes of incoming viruses and in
particular this are 462 qvariant is
thought to have be associated with an
increased risk for having prostate
cancer all right now this mutation
actually decreases the catalytic
activity of the RNAs so it makes it less
efficient at chopping up RNA so some of
the ideas for how this mutation might
predispose you to prostate cancer maybe
it makes maybe it has an
anti a pop Tata cafetto and so you don't
normally clear precancerous cells and
therefore they progress the cancer or
another idea was that maybe this
mutation allowed you to be infected with
a virus which then led to prostate
cancer alright so the original idea for
looking for a virus etiology of prostate
cancer was this mutation in RNA cell
right so a group actually a multi-center
group decided to do this and what they
used was a microarray technology this is
a figure from the textbook showing you
how DNA microarrays work in this
experiment we are looking to see if a
virus infected cell makes different
mRNAs compared to an uninfected cell of
course the viral mrnas would be
different but you want to know if in
particular cellular mrnas or turned on
so what you do is you make these arrays
on glass slides we're a robot prints
individual DNA sequences hundreds and
hundreds of them per slide then you can
make RNA from your test subjects it can
be a virus infected cell or an
uninfected cell in the case today it's a
prostate tumor we're going to make RNA
from prostate tumors cut out of patience
you take the RNA you make cdna using
reverse transcriptase and you use a dye
coupled triphosphate so that the DNA you
make is labeled with a fluorescent dye
in this case one is red and one is green
so you can distinguish viral DNA from
cellular DNA you then hybridize these
DNA's to the slide you can do this very
readily and then you excite the floors
on the that have stuck to the glass
slide with lasers that excite at
different wavelengths and then you can
take photographs or digitize these and
analyze them so in this experiment if
you have a red dot it means that mRNA is
and do so each dot on the slide is a
different sequence come
referring to a cellular gene say so if
you have a red dot it means the mRNA is
up if you have a green dot it means it's
down because you have mostly cellular
green here and if it's yellow that means
the two are equal there's no change
alright so in this experiment they did
this was just DNA or RNA from prostate
tumors I do a microarray and on the
slide was not cellular mrna but viral
sequences and so this is called the
viral chip was developed by jo durie see
at UCSF and this viral chip contains the
most conserved sequences of about nine
hundred and fifty different viruses so
it's a scan to say what virus is in this
sample so they took RNA from tumor
tissues they took 19 different tumor
tissues which were collected at the
Cleveland Clinic and they extracted RNA
label them fluorescently and hybridized
them to this viral microarray okay not a
cellular microarray it's all viral
sequences because they want to know what
kind of viruses might be in the prostate
tumor and so here's an example of the
readout of a microarray so here on the
left is just part of it and this is
showing 502 retroviral sequences that
were on the chip they're all viruses
represented but we're just looking at
the retroviral sequences because that's
in fact what they picked up and these
are the positive hybridization signals
here each line it's a different sequence
and going vertically each vp is a
different patient samples with their 19
patient samples and you can see one two
three four five six seven eight of them
or or maybe seven I think it was a
reacting with retroviral sequences on
the chip so they're giving you a
positive signal and then they took these
positive samples and did a pcr for a
retro viral gene and this is the gag
gene and you can see these are all
confirmed positive as well
so this is a typical readout of a
microarray now here are the numbers so
they got a positive signal in 7 of 11
tumors homozygous for this variant so
our Q so its QQ and those are the red
ones here and then they also got a
positive signal in a heterozygous
variance so in other words the
homozygous have both mutations in RNA
cell and the heterozygous only has one
allele mutated so 7 of 11 for the RNA
art cube RNA selves area of QQ no
positive signals and three tumors from
RQ heterozygotes and one positive in in
the wild-type homozygote alright so that
was a gamma retrovirus that they pulled
out and so what they did is they went
back to some of the positive prostate
tumors and they use PCR to amplify the
entire viral genome from those samples
and this is what they got on top is a
diagram of the viral genome that was
cloned from one of these on this slide
are shown genomes cloned from two
different patients VP 35 and VP 62 so
this was cloned into pieces and this was
cloned in a number of different pieces
here and they sequenced them and they
find a typical retro viral genome with
the ltrs on either side it encodes a gag
and a gag pro Paul protein and an
envelope protein from a spliced
messenger RNA so they took this sequence
and they just compared it to the entire
database of viral sequences which you
can do very readily and they find that
it has very high identity with a number
of other retroviruses of mice all right
so these are all a variety of murine
retroviruses there are some exogenous
and endogenous viruses so these ARVs are
endogenous retroviruses those are pro
viral sequences that are present in the
mouse genome so they're called murine
endogenous retrovirus and then this
tells you what chromosome of the mouse
they are integrated into chromosome 147
cetera so this new virus that they found
in a prostate instead
prostate tumors had high homology to
murine retroviruses and here's a
phylogenetic tree of the sequence to
show you that and the red are the
samples of three samples from prostate
tumors different patients VP 3562 and 42
so these three samples are identical or
virtually identical one or two base
differences so you see a hundred percent
identity here and then they're compared
to a number of other retroviruses you
can see these are some endogenous
retroviruses of mice and some exogenous
one moloney murine leukemia virus here
more endogenous and then at the bottom
feline leukemia virus Gibbon ape
leukemia virus and koala retrovirus
these are more distant so again this
shows that they're highly related to
murine endogenous viruses in particular
what we call zeno tropic murine and
viruses those are the ones with the X
here and so that's why the virus was
called Zeno truck murine leukemia virus
related virus XMRV so murine leukemia
virus because it's related to these
viruses of mice and then Zeno tropic is
it is the name given to these certain
kinds of murine leukemia viruses which
we'll talk about in a few moments so
this is how the RNA cell genotype
tracked with xmrv so this is showing you
the PCR positive and negative for xmrv
according to our nasl genotype the
double the homozygous mutants the
heterozygous and homozygous wild-type so
you can see eight of 12 8 of 20
positives out of the homozygous mutant
two heterozygous and the wild-type so
according to this it looks like the
virus preferentially infects people with
disarm a cell mutation turns out that
that doesn't hold up subsequently but
that was one of the interesting
observations from this paper so here is
a section of prostate tumor to show you
the presence of this virus these are
again tumors sectioned and hybridized
with new
bioch acid probes derived now from XMRV
and these are tumors tissues you can see
the H&E staining on the left here and
then in the middle these blue sections
are showing you cells the green dots are
the viral hybridization signals so this
is called fluorescent in situ
hybridization or fish because the probes
are labeled fluorescently the cells are
counterstained with a nuclear stain the
nucleus is blue so you can see that
these viral probes are hybridizing with
cells in these sections of prostate
tumor so this is one evidence that
they've set forth to show that this
virus was actually infecting the tissue
and was not a contaminant and here they
took a monoclonal antibody and stained
those tissues as well again they cut up
prostate tumor tissues stained them with
a monoclonal antibody against the gag
protein this is a structural precursor
remember of spleen focus forming virus
another retrovirus and this antibody is
used because it reacts with a wide range
of murine leukemia virus is not only the
xena tropic but also polytropic andy
control which we will define in a moment
and you can see here these cells are
staining red and that's showing the
presence of the viral protein so the
previous slide showed there was viral
nucleic acid in the cells and the
prosthetic tumor cells here we see that
there's viral protein in the prostatic
tumor cells as well so the conclusions
of this study the xmrv detected in
primary human tissues no mouse sequences
they did a control looking for Mouse gap
th they weren't found infection seems to
be restricted to samples with the QQ RNA
cell genotype they found polymorphisms
in the virus from different patients
slight sequence variations very minimal
though and they suggested this indicated
that these were independent infections
viral nucleic acids and antigens were
detected in tumor tissues so they
conclude it's probably not a contaminant
and it's the first example of human
infection with a murine leukemia virus
so this was the paper in plos pathogens
in March 2006 I was a collaboration
between the DC lab at UCSF and the
Silverman lab at Cleveland Clinic which
provided the prostate tumor samples some
of the questions raised by this study
first of all this virus has no oncogene
you remember that many RNA tumor viruses
are oncogenic because they have an
oncogene in them but the sequence of
this one showed there's no oncogene so
how does it cause prostate cancer
another interesting thing which we
didn't point out in the sections but the
genome is found in stromal cells not the
actual carcinoma cells in the prostate
samples well it just is funny because
you would assume that the viral genome
is present in the tumor cells and that's
not the case these data don't prove it a
link of the virus with cancer they just
show that there's an association so you
have to do much more than then show an
association of a virus with a certain
disease and finally where did this virus
come one from it's a murine virus which
we say is infecting people so let's take
a look at the virus before we go on this
is a retrovirus of course and it's a
gamma retrovirus so we talked in this
course mainly about lentiviruses the
gamma retroviruses are different they're
prototypical retroviruses envelope with
glycoproteins in the envelope and of
course to RNAs in the core along with
reverse transcriptase integrase RNA sh
and the protease so this virus was
eventually discovered the actual virus
by taking that sequence making a
complete DNA copy of the viral genome
putting that into cells I didn't I just
added this this morning so it's not in
your printout yeah I guy I wanted to add
a few things but it's just a picture of
the virus and they transfected this DNA
copy of the genome if the cells and
viruses were produced in these are the
particles by eamonn ease again our
typical retro virus particles about a
hundred nanometers in diameter so gamma
retroviruses are simple retroviruses
they only have a couple of genes as
opposed to HIV which are more complex
their widespread in nature they found in
mammals of all sorts birds reptiles they
can be spread as exogenous via
virus particles going from animal to
animal or they can enter the germline
become integrated and be passed from
parent to offspring in the germline so
they're commonly transmitted vertically
mother to offspring and they can
initiate a very Mia in the offspring
when so transmitted they cause a variety
of diseases leukemias cancers
neurological degeneration and
immunodeficiency when they do cause
cancers these arise by insertion ille
activation of proto oncogenes remember
are any tumor viruses cause cancers in
various ways and one of them is to
insert and activate next to a
proto-oncogene and when you get infected
with these viruses its lifelong because
it integrates into your DNA of course so
the murine leukemia virus the endogenous
murine leukemia viruses to which this
XMRV is related there are four classes
and they're called eco tropic zeno
tropic poly tropic and modified and this
is just these are just diagrams of their
genomes for you to look at the original
words are based on host range that was
determined a long time ago eco tropic
for example means that these viruses
will infect the mouse that they're made
in but not other animals zeno tropic
means that the mouse that produces these
viruses is not infected by it the xeno
tropic virus only infect other animals
mostly other non rodent species non
mouse species but some mice apparently
are susceptible and poly tropic retro
viruses infect both the mouse and other
species as well so this was just an
early classification used based on host
range which is still used today so the
virus that we're talking about today is
you know tropic means it's not infecting
the mouse that it's produced in only
other animals so the pathogenesis of
some of these eco tropic viruses and
mice in in some mouse strains like a kr
a lab strain the mice die within a year
of thymic lymphoma and that's because
these viruses integrate next to a
proto-oncogene
so what happens was when the mice are
born they are infected by an eco tropic
virus and then eventually they die
within a year of thymic lymphoma induced
by this virus just to give you an idea
of some of the pathogenesis of some of
these viruses Xena tropic ml vs were
discovered in the 70s as retroviruses
from mice that could replicate in rat or
human cells but not in mice that's the
definition of xena trope the receptor is
called XP r1 and the mouse gene is
mutated so that this XP are one cannot
serve as a receptor for Xena Tropic
viruses in them so that's why the mice
are not infected they have apparently
evolved a mutated form of the receptor
that prevents infection but XP our gene
of most mammals including us is
permissive for Xena Tropic virus
infection so because of this receptor
block in mice there's not a lot of virus
produced in mice they have a few pfu
maybe in them because the virus cannot
spread but if you take a human tumor and
put it in a mouse which is a common
practice to try and grow the tumor and
perhaps make a cell line that human
tumor will be infected by Xena trophic
murine leukemia virus it's a beautiful
way of recovering viruses from the mice
because the human tumor cells are
totally permissive for virus replication
and this was the this was learned a long
time ago and people were isolating
viruses from these human tissues and
they saw new human tumor viruses but
they were just Mouse viruses being
recovered so they were called rumor
viruses not tumor viruses more some more
facts on Xena tropic MLV their inherited
of courses endogenous proviruses 10
about 10 to 20 copies in all inbred mice
trains and some wild subspecies there's
more Pro viruses some of them are
infectious and produced virus and as I
said they can infect virtually all
mammals except some must species in mice
they're not directly pathogenic and we
don't know really what they do in other
species although we'll see an experiment
today where we address that
they're common contaminant as I've said
and related eco tropic MLB's cause
variety of diseases and mice as we have
said so where did this XMRV come from
that we've isolated from prostate tumor
DNA so these patients were from
different parts of the US you'll see
some other patients later on also in
diverse parts of the US which suggests
may be limited point sources because
there's so little variation in the virus
maybe this is a fairly recent event
because there's not much sequence
variation this these human isolates are
very similar to XM x z no tropic ml v's
and mice in the genome of a common mouse
strain we don't find XMRV but when these
studies were first done not many mouse
strains had been examined for these
sequences so the question is is the
virus endogenous in any lab strain so
here is again a sequence line up between
these patient samples you see prostate
cancer here very closely related to
murine leukemia viruses and so what
happens in mice this is just a
theoretical idea for how it got into
people so mice make exogenous murine
retroviruses the eco tropic viruses for
example they can infect mice these
eventually become endogenous so they
integrate into the genome and these mice
live with these infections for many
years eventually the my sins are
selected for a receptor mutation which
makes them resistant so they don't get
disease and now we have Xena tropic MLV
these mice make virus but they can't be
infected by it although the virus can
spread to other species so the idea is
that one of these kinds of viruses
somehow infected people the question is
was there one case of the virus going
from a mouse to people or were there
multiple incidents was there any human
to human transmission we don't have any
answers to these questions from what
I've told you so far so I just want to
tell you about some studies where they
have looked in the mouse genome to see
if there's a related virus so again we
start with XMRV the virus isolated from
prostate tumors
you make primers that will detect it in
the mouse genome and this is an example
of how you can use pcr to specifically
look for XMRV it turns out that XMRV has
a 24 nucleotide deletion right here
which is unique and so you can design
pcr primers that span it and are
therefore going to amplify specifically
XMRV in Mouse DNA all right you want to
do this because there are lots of
related sequences in the mouse genome
and you don't want to see those you just
want to see XMRV so this was done in in
a number of laboratories and these are
some of the mouse DNA's that were tested
for XMRV of course mus musculus is a cut
is the origin of many lab strains which
are shown here some of these may look
familiar to you Bob see c57 black then
there are many substrains as well of
most musculus all these were looked out
than their different sprains Predis cook
I etc dunny and then it was also looked
for in rat cells and a variety of other
cells as well and so what was found was
that inbred mice of all those strains
contain about 10 to 20 Xena Tropic
viruses related to XM RV but none of
them the ones that were looked at
contain a single pro virus with the
exact sequences of XMRV that is the
virus that we got from prostate tumors
so none of these mouse strains have xmrv
that have related Xena Tropic viruses
but not xmrv so it's not likely that any
of those viruses in the mice were the
immediate source of xmrv so well it's
thought is that these results mean that
there was a single cross-species
transitions transmission sometimes
recently and then the virus adapted to
humans so it became different now it's
different from the endogenous XMRV xml
vs so that's one idea or maybe there is
an endogenous pro virus in mice which
hasn't been detected yet and that
could have led to XMRV infection okay so
remember this is a retrovirus that
infect cells the RNA is converted to DNA
the DNA goes in the nucleus and it
integrates and forms a proviral DNA you
remember that this integration step is
an obligatory step in retro virus
replication the virus cannot replicate
without integrating so a very good test
of whether in fact a cell is infected
with a retrovirus is to find the
integration site in the chromosomal DNA
right so you could take DNA from these
prostate tumors and ask is there
integrated retro viral DNA because what
was done before was to take RNA from
these tumors and make DNA from it all
right that doesn't tell you that it's
integrated remember when you when you
integrate a retro viral genome there's a
host target the host target sequences
are duplicated and you lose some
retrovirus sequence so you can tell a
retrovirus integration site if you
sequence across the integration site
across the retrovirus into the cell DNA
you can tell that it's retro viral
because of these features so this is yes
could you check for protein expression
so in the prostate sections that's what
they did but it doesn't prove that
there's an integrated pro virus which is
really a more gold standard proof of
infection than finding protein yeah yes
you lose to news nucleotides from either
end of the retroviral sequence and then
you duplicate the target site in the
hosts DNA that that it's integrated into
so this is the host target this pink
sequence here and you can see it's
duplicated on either side and then these
two properties to terminal bases are
lost in the virus the TT in the AE vaa
are gone right so you see that and you
can tell it's an integration sign all
right so then this was looked at in this
paper in october two thousand eight
integration site preference of XM RV a
new retro virus associated with prostate
cancer so what they did is they took DNA
from prostate tumors they cloned out
nine xmrv integration sites from nine
patient actually i think they're more
than nine there nine patients I think
there are fourteen integration sites
from nine patients and they sequence
them and they found there's no
integration near oncogenes which they
wanted to see because that's that would
be how it would cause prostate cancer
and there's no integration near tumor
suppressor gene which might disrupt it
so here are just three examples of this
to give you an idea what the data look
like so on the top here is one
integration of XMRV and so they sequence
across one of these integration sites
and you can see where the virus begins
and it goes into cellular sequence and
you can just take the sequence you get
and blasted against the genome sequence
so you know exactly what chromosome this
integration occurs and what genes are
nearby so for example there's a creme 5
gene here which encodes a transcription
factor that's one integration site
there's another one here within a gene
and fat and then another one here within
a different gene so in all cases you can
tell exactly where the integration has
occurred so this was thought to be good
evidence that there is actual bona fide
infection of prostate cells because an
integration site dura is derived by
viral replication okay so now after
these studies came out a number of
people began to look in other areas of
the world in people with prostate tumors
to see if this virus is present because
that's one of the first things you do if
you suspect the virus is causing a
disease you start looking in more cases
and do some epidemiology so here is the
study from Germany prevalence of XMRV
and sporadic prostate cancer so now
we're not worried about the RNA cell
mutation anymore so they found they
looked at 105 tissue samples from people
with non-familial prostate cancer they
found one positive for XMRV out of 105
using PCR they also found one in 70 in
tissue samples of men without prostate
cancer so they concluded that at least
in Germany XMRV is not associated with
prostate cancer so that's november two
thousand eight couple of years after the
original story was published yes
they I have no I'm not aware of any
study that has attempted to make a
correlation between the two diseases no
we are we're going to talk about the
chronic fatigue syndrome results in a
moment but I've not I don't know of any
that the attempt to do both it's same
virus that's implicated in both though
this was a study in September 2009 from
a group at University of Utah and one of
the individuals they re Lessing used to
be up at Columbia and she is a
pathologist and she looked at 233
prostate tumor sections she's a
pathologist and a virologist 109 benign
101 benign controls she found the DNA by
pcr in six percent of the tumors and in
two percent of the controls she also
looked for protein she found it in
twenty-three percent of the tumors and a
four percent of the controls in this
study contrast to the first one she
found that the protein the viral protein
is predominantly found in malignant
cells not the stromal cells which are
the non-malignant part of the sections
okay so this is a bit different but she
also is finding XMRV consistently in
prostate tumor so this is an example of
a section of a prostate tumor this has
been stained with an antibody to one of
the viral proteins now this antibody is
made against XMRV virus so ela singh
propagated the virus and injected it
into rabbits and made into bodies so now
this is the brown staining is where the
antibody is reacting with proteins and
these are all malignant epithelial cells
in the prostate section and the stroma
which is marked with an S here is not
staining so this makes more sense in
terms of the tumor the actual malignant
cells are now expressing the viral
protein okay so another study in October
of 2009 this from another German cohort
of patients lack of evidence for xmrv in
German prostate cancer patients they
looked at 589 prostate samples and 146
see
samples from people with prostate cancer
and they found no XMRV by pcr and no
antibodies by eliza in any of the sarah
so again this is a German study so they
said maybe there are some geographical
restrictions on where this virus so
subsequently many studies have been done
in many different areas looking for the
presence of this virus or viral sequence
or antibodies to it in a variety of
prostate cancer patients and these are
the studies that find the virus in pc at
the original one from ucsf 9 of 86 this
is the one from ela singh at University
of Utah and then there were two others
showing positivity in patients from the
US 11 of 40 positive for antibody in
this study seven positive for pcr and
here 32 of 144 in the u.s. positive by
pcr but mostly they're there are many
studies now that find very little or new
no XMRV and prostate cancer specimens
you can see them here from various
countries around the world Europe Asia
Central America us so this one in
particular 0 out of 800 prostate tumor
sections this one was done at the NCI at
the same time in July of 2009 a paper
was published saying entitled multiple
integrated copies of XMRV in a cell line
called 22 rv1 so remember that not that
I'm going to ask you on an exam but
it'll come up later 22r v1 is the cell
line derived from a human prostate tumor
and so they found that the virus that is
produced by this human cell line is
basically xmrv it's the same virus that
has already been found in prostate
tumors this was what we're talking about
this cell line was produced by taking a
piece of a human tumor and injecting it
into a nude mouse a mouse without an
immune system it's called
xenotransplantation the purpose is to
grow up the tumor they pass it from
mouse the mouse and eventually make a
cell line out of it and
that's the cell law in 22 rv1 so the
sequence of that virus is a nearly
identical to the XMRV that's been
isolated from prostate tumors and the
authors conclude quote we conclude that
the 22 RV one virus is XMRV and is not a
mouse Nina tropic virus acquired during
passage of the cells in culture or in
mice so they said yeah this is XMRV it's
not it's not a mouse seen atrophic virus
so this is an interesting observation
this cell line which is derived from a
prostate tumors making the same virus
that's isolated with patients so this is
the time was viewed as support for the
idea of the etiology of this virus and
prostate cancer because it's isolated
from a prostate tumor all right so now
we move on to a different disease and
this is a paper published in October of
2009 by a group in Nevada working at an
institute it's actually a collaboration
but the Nevada there's an institute
which is has a hot focus on patients
with chronic fatigue syndrome so they
found XMRV and blood cells of patients
with chronic fatigue syndrome this is a
collaboration between the group at
Nevada the Silverman is from Cleveland
Clinic and he originally was involved in
the prostate tumor study and then there
are also some individuals from the
National Cancer Institute on this paper
so let's talk a little bit about this
disease chronic fatigue syndrome has a
number of names you'll see it CFS CF I
dsme my logic myalgic encephalitis
chronic fatigue immune dysfunction
syndrome unknown etiology estimated 17
million cases globally although there
are various numbers you will find a big
problem with this disease there's no way
to diagnose it very readily there's no
laboratory test you have to do patient
interviews and apply criteria and decide
whether a patient has this disease or
not it's some of the characteristics
include severe incapacitating fatigue
not improved by rest and certain
symptoms lasting at least six months
difficulties problem with concentration
short-term memory joint pain muscle pain
tender lymph nodes sore throat and
headache post exertional malaise and
about a quarter of the patients are
fully disable them unable to work and
there's a pattern of relapse with this
disease it can become better and then it
can go away so we have relapse and
remission it's it's also characterized
by a low-grade immune upregulation
poorly functioning and kay sells there
are also some CNS abnormalities and
problems with metabolism and what has
been observed over the years of study of
this disease is that there are a lot of
latent infections with various herpes
viruses particularly BBE and CMV and
also some entra viruses and other
non-viral microbes may trigger it so
this group in Nevada decided to look at
whether these patients contained XMRV
because there was some suggestion that
our nacl it was was different in certain
patients with chronic fatigue syndrome
so they so RNA cell has been associated
with a virus and prostate cancer so
let's look in these patients so since
student Nevada had a large repository of
patient samples so they took the blood
cells from these made DNA from them and
did PCR so this is PCR using peripheral
blood mononuclear cell nucleic acids
using primers specific for this virus
xmrv so you can see that a good fraction
of the samples are positive for either
the gag or the envelope gene of the
virus so these are individual patient
samples and they also compared normal
controls so you can see the note there
is one positive on this set of normal
controls here so 68 have 101 CFS
patients were positive by pcr and eight
out of 218 normal controls so they
sequenced the virus and it's up here in
red xmrv and the virus from this study
has WPI in front of it as opposed to vp
62 and 42 which are the samples from the
original prostate tumor
study and these are identical same virus
maybe one or two or a few I mean
nucleotide differences so they're on a
phylogenetic tree they're all up
together here and again they're very
related to the Xena Tropic viruses which
are shown here and less so to the
polytropic and modified poly tropic
viruses on this tree I want to show you
just a few experiments which they did to
characterize the serology of this
infection so up here on the upper left
is is flow cytometry where they take
peripheral blood cells from either
healthy people or a number of cases of
individuals with chronic fatigue
syndrome and they sort these cells and I
flow cytometer and they use antibodies
against another retrovirus not XMRV but
they use antibodies against against
spleen focus forming virus remember that
was an antibody used in the first study
because it reacts with a lot of xena
tropic marine retroviruses and you can
see the normal blood peripheral
mononuclear cells don't shift to the
right when you add these antibodies but
then the blood of the five patients here
the peripheral blood cells shift to the
right which means they're reacting with
these antibodies so it tells you that
there are some retro viral proteins
being expressed in these blood cells
they also did a variety of other
experiments including western blots they
would culture these peripheral blood
cells in vitro with susceptible cells
and then they would do western blots on
the extracts and you can see they can
detect viral protein envelope and gag
proteins on Western blot using
antibodies to either again spleen focus
forming virus or another murine leukemia
virus and that's what most of these
studies are they also found that the
viral proteins were in cd4 positive T
cells and in B cells and they were able
to culture this virus by mixing again
peripheral blood mononuclear cells from
patients with a cell line that is
susceptible to the virus so that allows
you to
by the virus that's present and you can
see the viral particles here they're
very much like the viruses that are made
by transfecting cells with the XMRV
clone and finally they showed that a
number of patients 9 of 18 patients have
antibodies to the virus so for this they
do another flow cytometry experiment
except the cells used here the cells
that are sorted are not blood cells from
the patients but they are a lab cell
line that expressed retro viral
glycoproteins on their surface so then
you add serum from the patients and you
ask does that serum react with these
envelope expressing cells all right so
here we have normal Sierra normal plasma
from a patient without the disease and
then you have here a plasma so this is a
another control sorry this is another
sample of a patient where the they are
reacting with spleen focus forming virus
expressing cells so this tells you that
the syrah have antibodies that
cross-react with spleen focus forming
proteins again it's not XMRV it's a
related virus so the patients appear to
have virus in their peripheral blood
mononuclear cells and they also appear
to have antibodies in their blood okay
so to summarize that up we have another
association between xrm RV and a
different disease chronic fatigue
syndrome again is it a causal factor or
a passenger we don't know from this
study we have to do much more
epidemiology and basic research to
answer that in this study there was no
correlation with the RNA cell genotype
so that was what led them into doing
this but there isn't a correlation
between whether or not you find X
the other point that is interesting is
that they found the virus sequence
present in three point seven percent of
healthy blood donors so if you
extrapolate that across the u.s. that
means there are several million people
theoretically that have this virus in
them so immediately this became a
concern for the blood supply whether the
virus is present and whether we should
worry about that so you can imagine that
that would be an issue so a number of
other studies rapidly followed this one
September 2010 this is from the NIH and
here they again took blood from patients
with chronic fatigue syndrome and
healthy donors and they did pcr and they
found viral sequences in this study but
they weren't XMRV these were polytropic
MLV these are a different tropism group
than the xeno tropic ones so they found
these sequences and we'll call them MLV
like sequences in 32 of 37 CFS patients
in 3 of 44 healthy controls they had
some paired samples from patients 15
years apart so they were able to test
those and seven of eight of those were
still positive and as I said these are
more related to poly tropic MLV subs not
it's not XMRV it's different and there's
more sequence diversity so if you do a
phylogenetic tree of the envelope and
gag sequences you see XMRV that we've
been talking about is right here here's
the CFS sequences WPI and VP 622 the
prostate sequences here are some murine
endogenous retroviruses and here the
sequences found in this study so there
they're tracking with poly tropic or
modified polytropic retroviruses of mice
here and also here compared with xmrv so
this was puzzling because it was a very
different virus it's a Marine retrovirus
but it's not xmrv so it's it was strange
that a different virus would be found in
the same types of patients and here's a
summary then of all the studies that
followed
looking at xmrv in patients with chronic
fatigue syndrome so we have the original
study which I first described in the US
these are patients in the Nevada area
actually there are patients from
different parts of the US and then the
second study which we just described
also us patients 3237 positive but there
have been many that fine little or no
virus in patient samples and these go
from the UK the US China Germany and
Japan and you can see the numbers most
of them are pcr-based there's a little
bit of serology involved as well the
most recent one looked both by pcr and
serology they also attempted to grow
virus from the cells in a similar way as
the original study reported but didn't
find any of it while this is all going
on this group ela sings group in a
couple of others looked to see if any of
the AIDS antiviral drugs could inhibit
XMRV so this pub this paper is an
example raltegravir is an inhibitor of
XMRV so this is a by a drug that is used
to treat HIV infections it's an
integrase inhibitor it's also a potent
inhibitor of XMRV and this is a table
summarizing the different HIV drugs that
are active against H XMRV of our aunt
reverse transcriptase inhibitors and 2
integration inhibitors so immediately
there are a number of patients with this
syndrome in the US immediately a number
of them began taking these drugs
off-label so the HIV antivirals are FDA
approved for use for treating aids but
any prescription drug can be prescribed
off-label for another use by a physician
that's legal and so a number of these
patients have been treating getting
treatment in this way for this disease
so taking it for chronic fatigue
syndrome assuming that xmrv is the
etiologic agent and another study was
published shortly
after that where they infected rhesus
macaques with the virus so they took
five animals and they put virus
intravenously into these animals the
animals develop a transient viremia and
then they become chronically infected
for long periods as you would expect
from a retro virus infection the virus
coat the very mia goes away after a
month and then nine months later they
detected it again so there's periods of
inactivity and activity the viral
proteins were widely disseminated in
monkey tissues but in very specific cell
types T cells again which is one of the
cell types found in the CFS study
macrophages epithelial cells they also
found extensive reputation in the
prostate so a lot of these properties of
infection are somewhat consistent with
what we see in people and so a reporter
asked me does this mean that the virus
causes chronic fatigue syndrome so you
have to be very careful when you have
animal results that mimic what you see
in people because it doesn't prove that
the virus is causing the same disease
you can only do that by really good
epidemiology and eventually getting an
inhibitor and showing that it clears the
disease an inhibitor of the virus and
showing that it clears the disease now
we had a series of paper published at
the beginning of this year for papers
we're going to talk about right now came
out in this journal retrovirology the
first one entitled Mouse DNA
contamination in human tissue tested for
xmrv so in this study was a study of UK
CFS patients they found xmrv by pcr and
four point eight percent of prostate
cancers I'm sorry I said CFS this is
prostate cancers all of these positives
were also positive for Mouse DNA
contaminating Mouse DNA all right and
they also had xmrv negatives 20% days
were also twenty percent of those were
positive for Mouse DNA so mouths DNA
remember has related sequences in it
mouse genomes have ten to twenty copies
of integrated Xena Tropic viruses so
this said
tickle you have to be really careful
because in many labs there are mouse
sequences present if you work on mice
and one of the authors of this study
John coffin said he gives talks on this
and he shows a slide of my scrolling
over a scale in a laboratory so he said
at night how do you know what happens in
your lab mice can come and contaminate
your stuff if you leave your buffers
open they can go into them so he feels
that Mouse DNA is pervert pervasive and
that you have to be really careful so he
said this doesn't mean the previous
studies were contaminated but it just
tells you that you have to be really
careful when you do this type of stuff
another study came out of Japan an
endogenous murine leukemia viral genome
contaminant in a commercial reverse
transcriptase pcr kit so they found that
certain kits that you buy to do PCR some
of them have an antibody in them it's
called hot start to start the PCR
reaction these are mouse monoclonal
antibodies they're contaminated with
mouse DNA so you can get positive XMRV
PCR reactions if you use those kits so
they said okay this doesn't mean that
the previous studies were compromised
but you have to be really careful that's
the second paper third one contamination
of human DNA with mouse can lead to
false detection of xmrv like sequences
this was a CFS study from the US again
DNA from 112 CFS patients 36 healthy
controls the few xmrv positives also had
Mouse DNA in it so that they were
positive because they had Mouse DNA so
they actually developed a highly
sensitive assay for detecting Mouse DNA
in samples and they suggest this be used
in any study of the etiology of CFS or
prostate cancer so John coffin says PCR
is so sensitive if you took a drop of
mouse blood and put it in a swimming
pool yeah 30,000 gallons swimming pool
and then you took a mil of slightly
mixed it up took a mil of swimming pool
water you could detect
exim RV or XML related DNA in the DNA
from that drop because PCR is so
sensitive so this is why he says nicer
everywhere they can contaminate all
kinds of samples i think we probably
have Mouse nucleic acid a water if you
think about it comes from reservoirs
upstate right the mice are up there and
it's not filtered so there is actually
probably a low level of mouse nucleic
acids in water that you use in the
laboratory as well the fourth study that
came out in the same journal februari
2011 disease-associated sequences are
consistent with laboratory contamination
they also found that Mouse DNA can
contaminate patient samples but they
also sequenced the XMRV from that
prostate tumor cell line remember 22 are
v12 made by passing a human cell a
prostate tumor through mice they
sequence this virus and they sequence
multiple isolates and said the variation
they found in just all the viruses they
sequenced from the cell line is greater
than all the variation observed in the
human isolates from prostate cancer and
from chronic fatigue syndrome and so
they said this isn't consistent with a
process of transmission among humans the
virus should vary more it's more likely
to be contamination so I read these
papers and a reporter from the Chicago
Tribune called me and she asked me your
question what do you think and I said I
think this is the beginning of the end
and then that was published the same day
and all these patients started emailing
and posting on my blog and I went back
and looked and in fact none of this
means that the original studies are
wrong so I said I was premature at the
time but let's move on okay now a few a
little bit later just next month the
same group Greg Tower same journal
published analysis of integration sites
prostate cancer tissue suggests pcr
contamination so you remember at the
beginning I talked about using
integration as the gold standard for
retro virus infection of cells so what
greg did was he took the sequences that
were published of the XM our integration
sites in prostate tumor DNA and he found
that two of the 14 integration site
sequences are identical to sites cloned
in the same lab from a cell line
infected with XMRV so in the law in the
lab that had prepared the prostate DNA
for integration experiments they had
also worked with this cell line which is
a prostate tumor cell line they had
infected it with XMRV and had analyzed
the integration sites in that cell line
and they published them and what they
found in this group was that the
prostate sequences the integration sites
were the same for two of the integration
sites between the cell line and the
prostate tumor okay so this never
happens you never get identical
retroviral integration sites in a cell
line versus a another cell line or a
tumor so they said that these sites are
a result of pcr contamination in other
words when the DNA was prepared from the
prostate tumors in Cleveland maybe was
contaminated with DNA from this cell
line which already had integrated
retroviruses in it so contamination can
explain it whether it actually does is
not clear because the other 12 we don't
know whether their contaminants or not
or bona fide integration site so this is
currently being looked at as I
understand finally not too long ago
there was a conference in Boston the
18th conference on retroviruses and
opportunistic infections and a group
from NCI published that presented the
finding that xmrv probably originated
via recombination between to endogenous
marine retroviruses while the human
tumor was being passed through mice to
make this cell line 22 rv1 so what they
did is they sequenced mouse strain DNA
and they found precursors to xmrv in two
different strains of mice they call them
pre XMRV one in pre xmrv two and these
two Pro viruses
the idea is you they put the human
prostate tumor into a nude Mouse train
was that infected by the virus is in the
mice and then the two viruses recombined
to produce xmrv and you can actually do
the recombination of these two sequences
right in front of you you could take the
sequence and mix it up and you produce
exact xmrv from these two precursors
okay so is that clear these are from
mice these are two precursors that
recombined to produce xmrv so they feel
now I don't have the paper yet
describing us I was hoping it would be
published in time for this but it's not
out yet so we can't go over the details
but their idea is that this virus arose
in the 22 rv1 cell line a number of you
early 90s and it has contaminated all
the studies of XMRV in prostate cancer
and chronic fatigue syndrome and we only
have a handful of XMRV sequences from
human specimens and they're all
identical to this virus if we had more
diverse set of sequences then it would
support perhaps the idea that this virus
is involved but we don't have those a
number of individuals have said they
exist but they haven't been published so
at the end what do we know and what
don't we know what's the role in these
diseases is it the cause of the disease
is a passenger is it coincidence we
don't know how many people are actually
infected with this virus we don't know
how its transmitted it's probably
originated from mice if it in fact is
infecting people as I said one group
believes that it's all a laboratory
contaminant but whether it infects
people remains to be really seen one of
the problems that I have is that some of
the observations don't make sense
epidemiologically for example the first
study of xmrv and CFS patients they only
found xmrv and the other one I told you
about from the NCI they only found
polytropic em
v and these patients are collected over
many years from different areas of New
England so why would the type of virus
associated with CFS segregate according
to the laboratory not according to say
geographic area or some other
distribution why would a lab one lab
find MLV and the other find XMRV so it
doesn't make any sense to me as I said
there might be more diverse XMRV out
there but it hasn't been published so
far all the XMRV looks just like it was
made in the 22 rv1 cell line but some
other possibilities that still are out
there there could be pockets of local
infection that account for these results
contamination as I said might result in
these findings and a lot of that when
these when this conference finding was
put on the web last month a lot of
patients asked ok if this is a
contaminant why do I have antibodies
against the virus and the you can
actually there is a commercial test now
that will detect antibodies to the virus
in your serum but that's why I spent a
long time telling you about how the
tests or are run none of those tests
tell you that the antibodies are
specific for XMRV they just say they are
detecting a related virus so the
patients may have be positive 4x and RV
but they may be antibodies against the
different retrovirus so in fact it may
be that there are infections common
infections with mouse retroviruses in
people and so some of us have antibodies
but maybe it doesn't cause any disease
we don't we don't really know so cross
reactive antibodies may explain a lot of
the serology yes
drug samples do the patient's feel
better you know that this is anecdotal
and so it's not even worth considering
so I don't know maybe there are a
hundred people in the US taking such
antivirus you can find blogs where they
talk about it but it's not controlled
because you want to feel better if you
take these right so and as many
scientists have said the only way you
can find if an antiviral is effective is
due to do a properly controlled clinical
study you can't do anecdotal I feel
better types of studies and these people
who take it even if they did all feel
better that information would be useless
because you can't license a drug based
on that right so you know there's been a
lot of argument about whether this
should be happening and I mean a lot of
the patients are frustrated because
they've been sick for a long time and
they want to feel better so they want to
take drugs but you cannot use that to
drive any decisions about therapy
freakin here to my knowledge has never
been an instance where serum levels of
ours have been detected but the mystery
of whether up is any efficacy in
treating with drug and prevalence of
virus is CSO all the evidence so far has
been pcr and the only paper where that
any virus was detected was the very
first one from the nevada study where
they took lymphocytes and put them in
culture with a susceptible cell line and
then they were able to grow out virus
but that could be a contamination so you
don't have any measure of viral load in
these patients which is what you would
need right so actually it's interesting
to look at how the AIDS epidemic
progressed in this sense to get a sense
for how long it takes so you remember
from our talk about AIDS 1980 were the
first clusters of unusual infections
suggesting that something was going on
and two years later multi-city case
control studies provided evidence for
spread of an agent causing these
infections okay good epidemiology by
eight 1983 there were a thousand AIDS
cases documented the virus wasn't
isolated till July of 1984 so these
documented cases are purely from various
infections opportunistic infections and
so the virus is nineteen eighty four in
the first antibody tests februari of 85
and then you can start looking at
populations and saying do people with
the disease have the virus and then you
get the information you not even at that
point yet with xmrv where you can have a
reliable test we're not sure where to
look it's not clear that the blood is
the right place to look and then in
nineteen eighty seven eight
dt the first antiviral was approved by
the fda so and then heart came many
years later 1995 so at the minimum seven
years it took in the 1980s with pretty
good technology and this is because
there is a lot of virus present and the
diagnosis is very clear so we're only
was the first example of the first
isolation in 2006 so we're five years
down and we still haven't decided
whether this is the etiologic agent or
not but I think so if you want my
opinion it's not looking good but I
don't think the story is over in fact
there are a couple of papers in press
that are going to sort this out there's
a large study going on at Columbia
that's going to sort it out the and
you're going to know in the next two
weeks basically all right so they're
going to be published in various good
journals and they will answer the
question of whether this virus is
causing a disease or not whether it's
infecting people but the whole story for
the last five years has been amazing to
watch it's developed this is why I want
to tell you this story because it's
developing right in front of us I've
been following it from the start and
it's you can see what it takes to say
that a virus causes a human disease and
not only the science but you get to see
how the scientists get involved so the
group in Nevada who originally found
this have been the most ardent
supporters of the idea that the virus is
causing the disease but they have only
published the one paper and nothing else
has come out of that and they have said
at various meetings that they have a lot
of more evidence that have more sequence
variation but it's never been published
so rule the rule number one you have to
publish your data otherwise no one can
ever use it there's also been a lot of
conflict among the scientists because as
you can see there are people who find
the virus and people who don't so at
various meetings lots of accusations
and the patients now are getting
involved because the internet makes all
of this accessible in a way that wasn't
the case that even at the beginning of
the AIDS epidemic so they can see the
results themselves online they can go
they can blog about it they can post
comments I'm a firm believer that in the
end science always figures out what's
right not scientists science does and
that's because you have an interesting
question eventually the science will
come to the right conclusion but you
can't trust individual scientists
because they're all kinds of agenda so
trust science if you remember one thing
from the trust science not scientists
now we have one more lecture Monday by
dixon de Paume yay he's great very
entertaining so please do come and and
listen to about West Nile
you